what was the toughest moment of your
career yeah I think I've had a couple of
tough moments obviously missing a
penalty which everyone seems to remember
I think I got a bad injury when I was
playing for AC Milan I ruptured my
achilles and I got told by the surgeon
that I might not be able to play again
so that was a tough moment but the
toughest moment was when I got a red
card in the World Cup against Argentina
I know you've obviously both remember
that one that probably was the most
difficult moment because
you know people were doubting me as a
player as a professional and I kind of
uh went through a difficult time on and
off the pitch
but I was at Manchester United at the
time and I had a great manager Sir Alex
Ferguson that supported me a great team
great teammates and more importantly the
fans at Manchester United got me through
the difficult moments so
[Music]